welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so i just got to see sean glee another
great marvel movie where let's be honest
marvel
knocking out the park again
this is going to be another marvel
classic basically because it follows the
marvel formula
the simple three acts
the
the
sort of build up the reveal
the threat
the defeat and the rebirth
classic marvel signature is all over
this movie and i absolutely adored it
so let's break it down and just a
warning there will be some spoilers okay
so first of all marvel really think
ahead we already know this but actually
the easter eggs for this movie go back
all the way back to iron man we see this
army of the ten rings flag and logo in
iron man
in iron man 2 quite a lot we use the
agents of the army
obviously in iron man 3 with the
mandarin and the fake andrew
again trevor appears in this movie
trevor slattery ben kingsley is
phenomenally good as always
um
mind-numbingly stupid but on a level
that even homer simpson would consider a
bit thick but just beautifully acted
because let's be honest if ben kingsley
can do anything
it's before
all the way through as well the film has
a distinct
feel the martial arts is obviously of an
epic standard we see the first really
powerful fight scene on the bus in the
beginning of the movie the big reveal
that shang lee is actually not sean but
a martial arts master
the fight builds slowly there's one
enemy then two then three then four then
a dude with a machete for an arm it's
really reminiscent for me of the netflix
daredevil series in the first season
they have a battle in a corridor and
daredevil is still not in the full get
up he's still wearing the mask and all
that gear and but he's trying to rescue
a young child from the kingpin he walks
slowly up the corridor enemies come from
left and right
it's one long shot
it's a beautifully choreographed
feinstein that really we weren't used to
seeing particularly at that time at like
tv standard this was movie standard
choreography on the small screen
obviously those lines between movie and
tv have become a lot more blurred in
recent years through streaming services
but at the time it was
powerfully brilliant and the fight scene
on the bus is really
reminds me of that but it also reminds
me of the great golden harvest movies
and the you know the hong kong martial
arts movies bruce lee jackie chan one of
the scenes in particular that really
reminded me of those classic martial
arts movies
is they're battling on the outside of a
skyscraper and they're on the bamboo
scaffolding a 1.1 starts to break and
shangley's best friend katie is hanging
off the end and changling needs to save
her
this is a tool and a an a seeing sort of
room but it has been done before in
martial arts movies jackie chan has done
this more than once in his movies
it's done because it works and it is
beautifully filmed beautifully put
together and i've to be honest taken to
another level
but like i said this film
uses the marvel formula and it's not
just that classic form of the three acts
it goes a bit more than that
marvel movies always keep their
characters grounded
they're generally not overpowered
captain marvel to one side
um
they've generally flawed in some way and
shang lee is no exception he is just a
human being
but with this ten rings of power
so again elevated to that superhero
status
they do that through the details
things like when shangley uses the rings
to
he doesn't really fly but jump very far
he shoots them down they propel him up
and then he shoots him at the ground to
slow himself down before he lands
just details like that he doesn't just
do the like the superhero landing he
actually
there was actually thought and detail
put into it that he they realized he
would need to slow down he's just a
human being it would break his legs if
they didn't
there's a scene where he is in the lake
about to meet the guardian the dragon
um and they remember that he needs to
breathe so you can see air bubbles
forming and
him absorbing them sort of thing it's
details like this that allow the
character just to stay with two feet on
the ground and let the audience
stay with him
that it's based in some sort of reality
now dc
is not very good at this skill but
marvel is an excellent at it have taken
us right up to the edge of extraordinary
but never stepping over it into the
silly
and again they do this with this movie
and it shows it really isn't art and how
skillful they are at it that at one
point our
hero shangley is riding a freaking
dragon and at no point do you stop and
go well that's just stupid
you are completely with it it is done so
well and so carefully that at no point
do you question him battling um some
evil entity soul-sucking entity
on the back of
a dragon another thing they do a lot
though is they use the dialogue
they use the dialogue in very clever
ways one of the ways they do is they
never go too far with a dialogue
they never use a cheesy little one-liner
where a glance will do
a glance that done in the right setting
in the right context says a thousand
words they do this several times in the
movie something like
the father the main protagonist of the
movie dies gives his life to protect his
son
come back time a second
the two children look back
there's nothing to say at that point
nothing to say that will make sense or
not be cheesy so they don't say anything
they just look at each other and give
each other a look that tells us
everything going back to the protagonist
one of the things marvel does and they
do it again and again and again is they
make a bad guy that isn't really a bad
guy that we as an audience can kind of
relate to
they did it in the in the daredevil
series the kingpin character he actually
is trying to do something good for the
community his community
he does it in a bad way but he's trying
to do something good in his eyes
obviously we have thanos who in his mind
is trying to
save
the half that's left rather than
worrying about the half he's killing
the bad guy in shangley shangley's
father is very similar he is the real
mandarin he is the warrior of a thousand
names that's lived for over 10 centuries
and he's been fighting wars in the
shadows for all those years he falls in
love with this warrior princess from the
ancient mystical village
they have this
fight that's a dance of seduction they
fall in love he decides to put his evil
past behind him
he then
becomes that family man
his wife is taken away when his history
catches up with him
and then he
basically commits himself back into his
darker ways he is then tricked by an
evil entity to come to this village to
release the salsakin
monster into our reality but he's not
doing that because he's evil he's doing
that because he's desperate to get his
wife back
now shang glee can see that he's being
tricked and he's desperately trying to
stop him
they have a battle where
the rings are purple and his dad
symbolizing that mystical dark energy
and then they become golden colored when
they're on shangley when shangley takes
them when he earns them through battle
they become a golden color because in
chinese mythology particularly that
represents light and heat and good
energy the father then does obviously
what he has to do and he gives his life
to protect his son again this is
something we see in
marvel over and over again the final
thing marvel always does and they do it
again in this movie
is they have the comedy moments to break
the tension this is another mechanism to
keep it grounded and keep it realistic
the end of the avengers movie
height of tension height of drama we
think iron man's dead
hulk screams at him he wakes up and he
goes oh
anybody heard of shawarma let's go eat
shawarma i think there's a place around
the corner
in the final credit scene we don't know
what these rings are captain marvel has
just said she's never seen technology
like this
um intelligent hulk with his still in
his arm in a cast and his looks really
aged as well at this point he's really
gray hair and stuff
um they're saying they're looking at the
um rings wang has them in in the
mystical arts using the mystical arts to
like sort of scan them and stuff and
they're saying we don't know what this
is they're ancient and we don't know
what they are and wong is telling him
you've got a path now
not just him actually but his friend
katie as well you're going on a path now
on a journey
and you better get ready for it and then
oh we better go wrestling
or
and then they flash
to them singing karaoke which is just
beautifully done
it breaks attention it grounds the
characters back in reality and let's be
honest we see wong singing and that can
never be bad so if you're oman and iron
about whether to go and see shanghai
go
it is a classic marvel movie it is
brilliant and we're going to be seeing
this character in lots of different ways
in the coming years
i would actually love to see him on a
disney plus series of his own i think it
would work really really well and if you
are new to the channel please like and
subscribe hit that bell notification if
you would like to wear this wonderful
t-shirt that i'm wearing today you can
go to the link in the description and
you can purchase one of your very own
so thanks very much guys and i'll see
you next time
[Music]